I'm sweating my heart's palpitating the
cutest dog award goes to
[Music]
oh my God you guys you did this on
purpose
hi guys I'm Lucy Hale and in honor of
buzzfeed's first feature film about dogs
I am going to be playing the dog
cuteness bracket game let's go
French Bulldog
this is gonna be so many sword yeah I
might be in the minority but I'm gonna
have to say beagle
Australian Shepherd oh Shiba Inu Shiba
Inu I almost actually got a Shiba Inu
they're pretty perfect okay
golden retriever
Dalmatian
golden retriever it's really hard I mean
all dogs are perfect I'm just waiting
for the maltipoos in this stack because
obviously I mean I think it's pretty
clear I'm a crazy dog lady especially
about my dogs okay
Bernie's mountain dog and Siberian Husky
are Bernese Mountain dogs like the
really ginormous bear-like creatures
I'm gonna have to go with Bernice
a Yorkie Yorkshire Terrier oh Cavalier
King Charles
oh no why you gotta do this to me
I'm so sorry I feel bad
I have a personal
draw to your keys because I had one for
a while growing up but
Cavalier King Charles are so sweet
they've actually look like that emoji of
the big
the big eyes so I'm gonna go with Yorkie
on this one okay
blah blah
Pomeranian
Pomeranian definitely I've never met a
Chihuahua that quite liked me actually I
feel like chihuahuas are adorable but
they only really love their owners
I like that Pomeranians do that little
like thing
okay
English bulldog
and a Pug
oh boy this one's tough pugs just are so
expressive and like they have every
worry in the world like they're just
worried about everything and English
Bulldogs literally don't care about and
it looks like they don't care about
anything so they're like this is these
are very
opposite but I oh boy I love the
floppiness of English Bulldogs
last one is oh my God Welsh Court oh my
God you guys did this on purpose
[Music]
can I quit
oh I think maybe a dachshund because
their legs are just so small but also
corgis also have these really tiny legs
but my grandmother used to have a
dachshund okay now we gotta narrow it
down more
let's narrow this bad boy down all right
now we have English bulldog and a
dachshund this one's easier for me I'm
gonna have to say a document
or a wiener dog
Pomeranian or Yorkie yikes
golden retriever or Bernese
why is this the hardest thing I've had
to do in a while why is it that I could
easily do this with people
easily
but but with animals it's like
impossible okay Golden Retriever
beagle Sheba a Sheba okay
okay between a Golden Retriever and a
Sheba I'm gonna have to go with Sheba
yeah
and the Dachshund and a Yorkie I'm sorry
Yorkie I'm gonna have to go with
dachshund
all right
[Music]
I'm sweating
my heart's palpitating I feel like I'm
gonna get Bad Karma points for even you
know what that intuition's lighting up
it's telling me
that
the cutest dog award goes to
IBA Inu
and now you might ask why Lucy I
literally don't know I just remember
whenever I see one because they kind of
like
walk like this and they just have like
really human eyes
really proper and sweet I've never owned
one I've never known someone who owned
one I have been known to follow a few
Instagram accounts of Shiba Inus
um but I really am still wondering where
the Maltipoo was at
this game
listen I just want to let all the dogs
in the world know that you are perfect
you are whole you are loved and
I'm indebted to you and I feel really
bad if you agree with my winner let me
know but also while you're at it make
sure you go check out all the adorable
dogs in my new movie
[Music]